alright guys we've all been there
you're playing a game you're having fun
and then someone screws you over with
some dumb game breaking bugs but here's
the thing
not all bugs are bad some have become
what are called exploits mistakes in the
game that have turned into pillars of
competitive play so today we wanted to
run down everything through those
incredible important exploits to the fat
[ __ ] crazy bugs so here it is our top 10
bugs and exploits in competitive games
there's no doubt that League of Legends
has had its fair share of bugs and
glitches over the last decade in the
game's release but when those glitches
affect a professional game things can
get a little dicey that's why the
knock-up bug lands at number 10 on our
list just look at how ridiculous this is
even the casters are losing it to fly
the white shield pumps in stinky take
him down but he gets base tanks in to
try and get him Lola wants him but he
has to flush out to safety
whoa betrayed on top of the gentleman
who uses the term a true chopper odds
bowlers in turn the magical grunt one
I mean Tarzan took a trip to outer space
and I'll see whether he's actually gonna
let us know what afternoon that was a
magical journey any sports not all
glitches and exploits are associated
with negativity cheating or bad press
number 9 on our list is an exploit that
stems from the fundamental design of a
game that laid the groundwork for all
fighting games today
it's the accidental invention of combos
as we know them in Street Fighter 2
found somebody Erik Suzuki is a street
fighter specialist here at Capcom he's
got a special route combo for us what's
it called Erik
it's called Russia triple hit dragon
punch Danny okay cut to the game screen
I'll talk you through it you got it
prior to the game's release combos
weren't exactly prevalent so when
someone discovered what they thought was
a bug
it changed fighting games forever Capcom
never intended to let players chain
attacks together one after another but
when fans figured it out the developers
knew they had a homerun that little tiny
damage oh he could rape walk he's off
the wall almost one decides it taking
the number eight spot on our list is an
exploit that's been an integral part of
super smash bros melee for years
wavedash though the skill itself wasn't
intended to be a core mechanic in the
game it's become necessary in all
aspects of competition and smash players
wouldn't have it any other way
even steven toh mango hoping to extend
his tournament after a crazy thus far
catching the roll
okay looking for a ticket place they're
not gonna get it but he wavedashing
offered such a huge advantage over other
forms of movement that the developers
opted to nerf it in later iterations of
the game just to level the playing field
simply put without wavedashing you're
just gonna get slapped around and the
game will be over before you know it
yeah see Bango not not having any chicer
now when he knows he catched a shield
not a big deal I'll roll take a page on
the Tony Kim's book
he doesn't feed Nomura that Bango is
going to advance to grand finals coming
in at number 7 on our list is a glitch
that is honestly just unfair uncanny and
straight up broken the shield glitch in
Rainbow six siege no God please no no no
after making a brief appearance in 2018
the shield glitch made its return in
2019 when players in the game discovered
an exploit that allowed operators with
displayable shields to place it over
their upper body for the player with the
shield it was business as usual but
anyone trying to kill them was gonna
have a hard time and though who be soft
was quick to fix the exploit it made for
some pretty hilarious moments there's an
arm was being
oh nice I think one of these dudes is
about to do something very very bad cuz
Jaeger glitching yet again they be just
trying to get the perfect angle you
never know you never know can you zoom
and buddy I need a screen shot for
YouTube yeah there we go
there we go look at this dude if you
play or watch any kind of first-person
shooter
you probably heard the term wall bank
before help you might have even been on
the receiving end of an unfortunate one
now this problem is back back in
counter-strike 1.6 walls were paper-thin
which allowed players to shoot and kill
enemies through certain walls on the map
if they lined it up properly and though
the developers didn't exactly intend it
to be that way many players took
advantage of this feature just look at
this ridiculous and now infamous clip of
nothing at a LAN in German
[Music]
though the ability to wallbang in csgo
still exists it's drastically changed
evaluate it so that bullets do less
damage when they go through walls and
while we still have moments like bodies
iconic wallbangs phonemic huh take
shorty vice know one shot even that led
to instant nerves back in 2012 valve
release patched 6.75 for dota 2 that
among other things made a few tweaks to
Chen's abilities but somewhere along the
line things went wrong somebody [ __ ]
up and the result is number 5 on our
list the persecution starts now how does
so funny
can I just send him anywhere
[Music]
nobody can attack them because these on
the pitch dota players discovered that
they could use Chen's ability holy
persuasion to charm Roshan like he was a
snake they could wore him out of the pit
and hasn't followed them for an
inevitable victory to make matters worse
Roshan couldn't be attacked making him
an unstoppable and invincible game
breaking force be hopping has been
around since the late 90s and it's still
widely used in a variety of games today
but of all of them there is nothing more
historically broken than encountering a
crazed beat hopper encounter struck back
in source it allowed you to maneuver
across the map in a matter of seconds
and reach the enemy before they even got
to a bomb site are you talking dude man
I got bunny hop to get there before us
don't flash him you don't know when he's
coming crazy
and although be hoppin still exist in
csgo to this day the ability to get
around the map at that speed has been
nerfed into the ground that's not to say
that there aren't any more sick clips
though both teams have been throwing
absolutely everything at each other look
at this what on earth nifty Wow movement
boys and gets the incendiary down as
well as denying the tray coming in at
number three on our list is quite
honestly one of the most BM and
rage-inducing exploits you'll ever see
that's right we're talking about
wobbling and melee it's an infinite
combo that is exclusive to the ice
climbers and it's not exactly tricky or
complicated all you have to do is grab
your opponent and beat them until they
die literally this isn't the my case
that be seen
Oh God and there's the regrab yep
all the walk off the walk off that's it
and it's [ __ ] like felixstowe focus
on the wobble right now I think a
meeting one knots
and tava and there's really nothing like
waiting for your impending death
the second wobble starts then will hive
tweeting us your followers just ask none
o rolled into it that's a very very very
expensive roll yeah yeah that look we're
gonna paid what it's the light all right
now I'm checking Twitter tweet ahem Wow
my man is on social media right now
[Music]
there's no moment in cs:go history that
captures the very essence of exploits
like the controversial Olaf boost and
that's why it's taking the runner-up
spot on our list after getting stomped
by ldlc in the first half of the game
fnatic decided to pull out a last-ditch
boost strategy that turned their enemies
into sitting ducks
pretty standard game of oh do they have
a width roost going on currently yes oh
my god this is beautiful
cruises well he sees them now they're
straight headshot they have no idea
Smith's looking confused and dazed and
it's gonna be a fun
you'll see they just lost around to it
and they they still have no show Nexus
getting fired
there it is it is rainy down death from
above round after round the strategy
worked perfectly fnatic eventually won
the match but little did they know there
was a storm heading their way I just
think it wasn't fair
it's just shameless of them it was a
dirty trick I definitely can't just go
you know unquestioned the boost seemed
like a creative strategy that capped off
an unbelievable comeback
it was later deemed illegal and led to
fnatic forfeiting the major after hours
of demo review is they found that both
Smith's and Olaf Lannister's boost took
advantage or or were subject to this one
texture bug that that could be applied
to both of them
it's that hive mind right of the
community everyone hopping on that
bandwagon of disliking fnatic at the
time was kind of the cool thing to be
doing but still it left a permanent mark
on sports history hopping off our list
is a memory of one of the greatest dota
2 tournaments ever played it's none
other than Navi is infamous and game
breaking exploit the fountain hook from
ti3 using a combination of abilities
players could skillfully combine Pudge
as a meat hook and Chen's test of faith
to throw a hook across the map and take
whoever it hit back to the fountain for
a guaranteed kill & tongfu is going to
continue to push they're not done Mac
still hasn't even been used there's over
how run all the way back to the base
played up by the fountain we actually
just saw the chin Pudge combo at the
international that happened the strategy
itself was so cheesy and ridiculous that
it nearly defined the entire tournament
and was eventually to patched out of the
game you guys don't deserve it or
something like that and I like whatever
dude so there it is our top ten bugs and
exploits in eSports titles do you think
we've missed anything make sure to let
us know in the comments and don't forget
to Like and subscribe also please check
out our brand new story of podcast you
can find it on soundcloud or wherever
great podcasts are thanks so much and
we'll see you next week thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages